Peter Parker's rival from spider-man far
from home the hunky hunky Brad is gonna
become venom now a five year older Miles
Morales who is now the same age as Tom
Holland did you know they're hanging out
there becoming best friends and they're
both spider-man Flash Thompson will
become Green Goblin this is rogue theory
today we are predicting which of Peter
Parker's friends is about to blow our
freakin minds in the new spider-man
movie I'm Phillip Malina and with me
going rogue remotely are we got back
Joshua oven Shire aka joven morena
Mastro's okay movin yeah and the the
vovan himself Erik come on down I saw
how much time you did that's a clue for
that other video we made I hate
everybody how are you guys doing good
good we talked about it we are we are
all collectively okay yes marina didn't
say good so we'll check in with marina
after good oh wait marina how are you
feeling did you have bars I still don't
have my test results yet so I have to
stay home like I haven't left I mean
obviously I'm not going anywhere anyway
but I can't like go to this door you
know wow are you I do not want to talk
about it on on video no I don't care I
posted on this room I had I had a sore
throat and that was it and then and like
left I was like lethargic and sleepy and
like overly tired so I mean plug for the
city of Los Angeles like testing system
I got a test the same day nice it was
free so I throw my resolve so it's like
the chickenpox right we should have come
over to your house for a party so we can
all have you know yeah all right
all right guys that means take it easy
on marina her brain has a fever and the
only cure is going rogue okay just the
spider-man homecoming and far from home
both surprised us with new twists about
very
characters and Peter's orbit the most
famous one obviously beans India's
character so I'm gonna be like by the
way they call me MJ sometimes and I'm
just telling you that for the first time
now what's wrong with your hand and then
also flash we learned a little bit about
is not exactly the version of Flash
Thompson that we'd expected before uh
Nick Fury was a scroll it turns out and
so these exactly these films have said
we were talking about the sea the day we
realized they kind of keep surprising us
with who the characters are actually
from the comics rather than bringing in
more and more actors and new actors so
that got us thinking who do we already
know in the spider-man MCU who is
actually going to be revealed to be a
different character from the comics once
they get developed I'm talking heroes
I'm talking villains somebody with the
deeper identity from the comics pitched
me on which of the spider-man verse
characters are actually somebody else
okay uh I'll jump on this first in a
recent rogue theory episode actually I
pitched that venom to might include a
supporting role Peter Parker that shows
us the black suited spider-man so with
your permission Phillip I'd like to
build on that and stay in Canon in my
own universe permission granted
just try to keep it concise alright ok I
think we all remember spider-man far
from home and in my mind it left one big
loose in Peter Parker's rival Brad Davis
who could forget that hunk he crushed on
MJ he threatened to show her Peter
Parker's photos and it totally backfired
like first off don't you think MJ would
have been like so this guy's hooking up
but everyone sided with Peter there so
you got a match of Brad's gotta be
pissed like he spent five years climbing
the social ladder you know get in his
body in shape join in the basketball
team it's suddenly Peter Parker blips
back into his reality and gets all the
love that's [ __ ] right so I think
things are gonna get even worse for Brad
when Peter also gets away with Jay jonah
Jameson
out him at the end so if you think about
it all that really has to happen is Nick
Fury just calls up his scroll buddies
and says hey you got that uh that backup
video from London where he's
shape-shifted into Peter Parker reacting
to spider-man and Mysterio fighting on
Tower Bridge great let's just like drop
that to get Peter Parker an alibi
so it clears his name pisses off J John
Jameson really pisses off Brad because
finally had a chance to see Peter Parker
its name brought down but it didn't work
so here we are in spider-man 3 I'm
taking the note try to be concise though
like all of our Midtown high students
are now going to Empire State University
in Manhattan and Brad is like obsessed
jealous of Peter Parker and it begins to
obsess over him especially since Peter
Parker has some mood swings because we
know from my carnage to theory he's got
that symbiote detachment from his black
spider-man suit he's trying to shake it
so Brad follows him around he follows
them to the campus bell tower where the
symbiote rips off onto Brad turn them in
to venom that's right folks
Peter Parker's rival from spider-man far
from home the hunky hunky Brad is gonna
become venom nice yes all right I'm down
with that
Eric I'm loving the confidence of this
pitch you got a Rogi just for bringing
it today how about a venom colored black
Sparkle buck oh where did I go oh here
it is a good ooh
this shirt is made out of black sparkle
bucks I was gonna give him more druggies
but uncomfortable I don't want to see
where that get no you blew it but I do
like your theory though because I do
like this that we talk so much about
venom and spider-man being destined to
collide but because of the stupid
property issues right like and in tonal
differences we keep having to bend over
backwards to try to figure it out yeah
of how it could work instead of just
like you know what give it to somebody
else in there sure and then we'll just
have we'll have our own version of story
very solid Eric you get it you also get
a thumbs up Wow I'll take it
it turns into
Maryna you go yes okay so I have a pitch
that Flash Thompson will become Green
Goblin okay and this is whoa yeah this
is changing a lot of stuff I know but
they're they've already shown that
they're willing to change this character
already so um a little bit because it's
a person of color playing a role role
for a white dude so yeah they're already
willing to change stuff which I love so
here are the reasons that I think he
might become green golem um he's richer
his family is rich right so he has the
means to sort of secluded himself off
and go into his own technological
development he can Tony Stark himself
into like a cave but it's like a good
cave with a box of good scraps all so I
mean they all go to like a science high
school right like they all should be
pretty advanced oh yeah yeah inventors
is that what yeah yeah he already hates
Peter Parker right they already him they
already go going like this and he's
already demonstrating some abandonment
stuff with his parents he they're not
texting him back they're not meeting him
the neighbor at the airport when he
comes home from like a disastrous trip
they assumed he died that they would
meet him but they're not so I if it were
me I would be like having some issue
already ooh yeah I have a pitch in the
middle of this area yeah okay cuz here's
the thing that I'm gonna underline trip
for people to marina is is having him be
the villain of Green Goblin Flash
Thompson is Green Goblin not his dad or
anything cuz obviously we're going for a
odds Bourne switch yeah that's gonna
take
but if he's evil and his parents aren't
showing up and he's making a big deal of
it maybe he killed his parents already
and they're dead that's what Philip I
award you a green Sparkle but
wait yeah maybe because he's freaking
evil yeah and he's like pretending to be
sad he's like where are they like broken
minded or whatever he forgot that he
killed them Oh Joe broken - yeah any
weekend at Bernie's Thanksgiving Rita
you're killing it you're doing great
this is great when you jump in halfway
okay keep going
[Music]
- I did oh yeah okay great
I need that great I what what I like
about it is clearly it got my
imagination flow but also more
importantly I love it when they're
economical and they just instead of
bringing in bryce dallas howard for no
reason suddenly like in the middle of
nowhere we're two movies in and we don't
have any Osborne's sol-fa right like
like just somebody else is gonna be the
Osborne and it's gonna be teenager
versus teenager with spider-man almost
never gets to have just like a battle
against another super boys yeah weirdly
an old man you have to fight you ever be
a teen in high school and like an old
man yells at you and you're like am I
gonna fight I don't know your geometry
teacher in any you corner each other
yeah and he has a compass you have a
protractor yeah whatever you guys
Phillip melted one of his teachers
brains with his mind don't tell them
that story it's true broken he died yeah
good question if you don't know that
story uh
joven please fix everything
Hulk buckle up you new rockstars we're
going for a ride
whoo try to have a new catchphrase for
yours yeah it's perfect so we thought
we've seen some characters that we're
like in Peter Parker's friend circle
with your theories all good theories I
want all of them to be true at the same
time but I think we're focusing too much
on far from home and we did a step back
to homecoming
Who am I character that was introduced
in homecoming Oh was it done all of them
it was donald glover as aaron davis
which we know becomes the prowler from
the comics but what we aren't addressing
here is the blip five years have passed
for some people so Aaron with-with-with
dog lovers nephew which he mentions is
around he didn't disappear from the blip
he's had the last five years to grow up
to become his Nazi holder he's nothing
yeah Miles Morales Miles Morales come on
what if now in Peter Parker's high
school he sees this new guy that's in
kind of staying like low-key but people
still have like their attention on him
and we find out that his name is Miles
and then you're like oh miles and Peter
Parker are the same age now so we don't
get the the spider-man comic that we had
in in real life we get the spider boy's
story instead that's right there's a new
spider that that winds up biting now a
five year older Miles Morales who is now
the same age as Tom Holland and you know
they're hanging out they're becoming
best friends and they're both spider-man
so that's kind of boys yeah you said
spider boys for some reason even though
spider-man is already referred to as
spider-man spider guys I think it's
spiders man like it's bunnies general we
are still kind of finishing out this
entire story arc for Peter Parker but we
are being introduced to Miles Morales
because what does Sony have outside of
in their spider-verse other than their
sinister six it's just a bunch of bad
guys right now what they need is more
heroes that they can actually yeah
Holland being Peter Parker is that
because he's so young they can go
decades with him it's Peter Parker so
now they need another one like that they
need a Miles Morales which they can now
have like an ultimate spider purse as
well
they have him maybe interacting with
some of this the sinister six villains
if we do see it crossover yeah
and Miles Morales because that's what so
many needs right now they need some more
good guys to be followed along so but
that's that's awesome because yeah they
can have Miles Morales you can they can
live out the entire sinister six
plotline with Miles Morales it could be
really fun I I think this is a really
cool idea too because get a live-action
one joban is your resupplies encase
stayed that Donald Glover is the
character we already knew he was in
homecoming because yes so you are
disqualified the entire premise of the
question despite loving your theory was
who do we already know who's gonna
surprise us and he's someone completely
different
unless you're gonna quickly say that Ned
is his nephew and that's actually Aaron
Davis becomes kingpin just say Aaron
Davis becomes King good you're lucky my
zoom froze up and I'm not sure exactly
what happened here I'll leave it to your
competitors Erick and marina does joven
get any roadies yes I believe he
deserves at least one Rogi your honor
cowards you could have taken him out a
roadie for her pretty gentleman he gets
a roadie for involving donald glover in
any capacity um a roadie for joven
sounds like a children's book with guys
is that in that great alright everybody
give him back to me in the form of a
tweet that we can understand that
summarizes our theory damn it
okay my tweet is from at the Daily Bugle
but they have to put a string of numbers
behind it because it's already been won
so it goes I still believe the
spider-man is Peter Parker despite the
lawsuit that's being leveraged against
me by a disorganisation sword
luckily my intern Brad Davis is on it
but he hasn't been in to work yet today
I think I got there Bo Yassir hashtag
Brad is Vanina
mine is you said that is understandable
and that limits me honestly while Eric
didn't care it's Yeldon tweet for it's
the words Flash Thompson and then arrow
arrow and then knifey knifey and then
the two emojis of his parents and then
arrow arrow and then I think there's
green like goblin dude emoji that's like
alien oh yeah and those are the and it's
just that it's Flash Thompson arrow
arrow stabby stabby parents arrow arrow
om arrow arrow a microscope and then
arrow arrow alien green alien gotcha he
he gives us parents knives they turned
them into a microscope yeah and and an
inner abductive aliens and then they
discover alien yeah with the microscope
great terrible as always for both of you
so Javed go ahead it's fine I don't even
care anymore
rumor has it that Aaron Davis is middle
name is miles in homecoming Easter eggs
revealed next up on new rock stars oh
that's a great
tweet that wasn't happy really you
changed everything yeah I'm a Donald
Glover into Miles Morales I did all the
things but that was the only one there
was actually a tweet I was just well if
I am alright none of you get any
additional road games for the word
around but I do want to see those come
true let us know in the comments who's
theory joven had four so of any of these
six theories which one you guys want to
see come true but guys also something
that I've always wanted to come true is
the ability to get an erection it's
always wanted but sometimes it's alright
well one of them was abs the other ones
World Peace I'm saving it though um guys
blue Chu to the rescue okay who here
likes physical activities in the bedroom
in theory Eric isn't cursed yet I have
been told they are delightful Eric's
girlfriend's name is theory so I what
about if your performance in the bedroom
isn't as powerful as you might want it
to be well blue to calm offers the first
chewable versions of essentially Viagra
and Cialis and what's even better is
that they're cheaper because they're
made in the u.s.a and who knows boners
more than american doctors and
scientists so guys this is true you guys
know that i am a supporter of this
product i used it in a previous episode
of rogue theory i'm still recovering
from it what is really cool this is
legitimately how it works is how i
ordered it you get a free online doctor
consultation they help you find the
right dosage and then the ingredient
there's like two different kinds and
there's one that's better for
your wiener versus somebody else's
ding-dong and if you don't want to go to
a doctor's officer you can't right now
this is more complicated you just go to
this website it's super easy once you're
approved they just ship it directly to
your door they're always talking about
how the packaging is really discreet I'm
always talking about how I don't want my
package to be discreet and we get a
great deal if you go to blue to calm you
get your first order completely free
yeah I think you have to pay five bucks
for shipping but the order is free if
you use our promo code new rock with an
arm it will be if you use it and it's
blue to Kombi lue CAG w.com remember a
promo code new rock joven you want to go
and put in that order now or you know in
the meantime while you wait for your
boner to show up to the party there's
another thing you can do to make
yourself more visible down there who's
familiar with manscaping that's right
manscaped is our other sponsor this
episode so right now obviously we can't
get haircuts but that doesn't mean we
got to neglect the hair down there joven
joven why don't you show us what you're
working with oh yeah okay in the
meantime the weirdest thing is we didn't
have to blur it it's just in reality it
was like that it's just - yeah it's kind
of like a black hole time freezes in
there we've got some
precision-engineered tools for your
family jewels flambe okay so they spent
18 months designing this third revision
of the lawn mower which I've got right
here actually it's a lawn mower 3.0 I've
used the 1.0 the 2.0 and the 3.0 I've
got nothing left it's probably
legitimately like nobody's ever focused
this much on a ball hair trimmer and so
the fact that they spent 18 months on it
and
the third revision and even the
packaging is so nice for your package
Erik's going to I it's that means it
probably is the best one that's ever
been made it's waterproof it has a 90
minute battery it has an LED light so
you can do it in the dark
and so you don't to see your shame there
you go thank you for displaying
so manscaping accidents are a thing of
the past thanks to manscape skin safe
technology you know don't test that but
trust it they also have a quiet stroke
technology which is what I do in the
shower but there's the quiet stroke
it's a 7000 rpm trimmer motor in it but
we can get to 20% off and free shipping
with the code rogue theory at manscape
calm 20% off free shipping manscape calm
again promo code is rogue theory but
with no space again our PSA every week
how do you spell rogue rog ue rogue
theory not Rouge theory guys you ready
to shave on for you but mostly they just
benefit me marina you can manscape
that's a gender all right guys it's time
to move on to the discord rogue theory
segment of the episode so every week we
play rogue theory with our patrons on
the new rock star discord and the
pictures have been getting like stronger
and stronger where we're worried that
they're gonna start overshadowing the
pictures on the show I don't know why
ours make so much sense Jobe ins changed
okay so this week we had three patrons
pitch the plot for guardians of the
galaxy three and Gandalf and DBS they
both had really good ones
with so many emojis using them but the
winner was on punt alone their theory
had the guardians searching for Gomorrah
leads them to half world there they
encounter the High Evolutionary who
created Rocket Raccoon but the high
evolutionary's working on a new project
Adam warlock
he stole Adam warlock from Aisha during
the snap took advantage
giant battle between Aisha and the
sovereign they've joined with the guard
to defeat the High Evolutionary there's
a parallel to the yondu's story and the
Ravagers to the first two movies and a
post-credits scene with of course I'm
gonna assume a giant foot that says like
I'll do it myself whatever basically
Galactus isn't hook post credit scene
guys what do you think of that rogue
theory I love it yeah I agree with that
good yeah I like it because as much as I
loved guardians of galaxy vol 2 I think
the the new origin story for Adam
warlock is just like another birthing
pod creation of Aisha like there's more
to this guy and I'm and I would love it
like his story just gets more
complicated as opposed to just like a
perfect specimen that Aisha creates yeah
who would play the perfect specimen but
Jana Reeves she's she's making up [ __ ]
all right so you guys can also play a
long rope theory and if you win we'll
read it out here on the show and discuss
how you do it become a patron and rock
stars and join the discord second topic
for our team here though this is I'm
gonna say this might be the most
controversial topic we've ever done on
rogue theory maybe on the Internet
I don't go to many places on the
internet I'm not sure I all right I'm so
tired of talking guys I'm so sorry
audience members who don't like this
voice uh back to the future director
Robert Zemeckis did an interview last
week where he said this before basically
said the only reason Back to the Future
for has not happened is because he can't
think of a good enough idea for it so
first of all no one tried to actually
make Back to the Future for please do
not do it but if there's a gun to your
head your life depends on it and you
have to make a Back to the Future movie
I'd say you've lived a good life
but if some reason want to live and
you're gonna do it anyway what is your
good enough idea that fine let's do it
let's make Back to the Future for okay
really like mine no you [ __ ] I do I do
okay so at the end of Back to the Future
3 Doc Brown flies away in a
time-traveling train ok and that when he
goes he go he lands he makes a slight
miscalculation cuz this is not the
DeLorean it's a train so he is an uber
mad ways different got a power with coal
yeah yeah and he lands in the future to
discover that the human race is no
longer there earth is no longer viable
and our species is extinct so he goes
back to the last time that he was alive
and he realizes that he has to keep
himself alive long enough to in for him
to invent a spaceship that will get
everybody to Mars to recolonize a
different planet now he brings Marty
this is insane and I love it he goes to
the past future train and he gets Marty
McFly and Jennifer and they come back
because he needs them teenage Marty
McFly had on the first day yeah great
and he brings them back to be his
protectors because he has to work with
himself right to invent this spaceship
because he needs to of himself to do it
twice as fast to invent this thing
before the earth ends but the earth is
ending so basically it's a horror movie
in its final destination and Martin boy
yeah and Marty and Jen you've just added
that because while they're inventing
okay the earth is ending and it's trying
to kill them in a bunch of different
ways and Marty and Jennifer are
basically just being like yo yo people
feel like running from different things
to different things are they made of
metal it's like you're saying if like
time is trying to like find away like in
11/22/63 you know it's like [ __ ] keeps
coming up and like time is trying to
fight back against being minute
they're changing the future and there's
two Doc's working together so it's it's
messing with everything so the universe
is trying to kill them so they find they
invent the spaceship right and they've
invented it but in order to return space
and time and the earth and all universe
is back to normal Marty has to kill both
Doc Brown's and let them both die
I know it's emotion is just gone dark
it's yeah I will dump Brown and then you
deserved it cry movie so they and it's
also guys it pulls at your heartstrings
this is a great pitch I gotta say you
know you Reno stop I stop while your
head that's how you go rogue Lina
there's two rogue E's right there you
somehow made it connect to interstellar
that's right yeah what it is got some
weird things there that's not a light
bulb okay there you go
Eric you get a rogue e for your
contribution to that one where time is
fighting back sure alright that's itself
the promise of a landscape package on
your way your wife can thank us uh I
like also that Doc Brown finally gets
what's coming to him you know like this
guy let 9/11 happen like about time 1985
be there's no 911 Biff is there 911
so yes the best really quick I just
gonna say that's gotta be the the
tagline out of the movie Back to the
Future for it's about time that's pretty
good that's pretty good all right who's
next we are about to get Oh Eric you
ready no way no way I'm getting out of
the way of this this locomotive all
right joven at least please just make it
one concern clear same theory all the
way
see when endgame happened when we got
endgame it changed the game
it changed the endgame in the end it
changed the game okay so and keep happy
- back to the future love the science of
Back to the Future was completely wrong
so now Robert Zemeckis knows this he can
go back to his own movies and kind of
see it in a new light which then gives
him that Eureka moments like oh I know
what we need to do I now understand
time-travel because of endgame this is
how we do back to the future for did I
just go meta with my rope theory does he
get hit his head in the bathtub and yes
I do yeah so what happens is we see Doc
Brown much later in his life he's lived
a great life but as he's out
you know just tending to his garden in
his retirement uh there's there's a
strange gust of wind a little lightning
in the air and then all sudden froom
froom
the DeLorean shows up are we expecting
Marty McFly Nene it is himself
it is Doc Brown again visiting himself
to tell him that his entire science
thought process back in 1985 was so
wrong that it's not just one timeline
but one timeline on top of many other
timelines so every time they change one
thing it actually causes a bunch of
other timelines to sprout out in two
different directions so yes they may
fixed one single timeline if Marty's
parents but as they go back to try to
fix their timeline up like you know the
equivalent of putting all the guys in
the right spots they come back to the
future just to find out that this isn't
the future that they once left they've
gone back to a different future where
part Marty's parents they didn't meet
but they never fell in love and we're
now realizing that there are multiple
timelines with multiple Marty's and
multiple Doc Brown's and time is
essentially crushing itself because
there's too many variations in the
timeline so now another DeLorean shows
up and another Des Moines shows up and
we see different versions of Marty McFly
and Doc Brown each played by different
actors because any of these different
timelines it's actually affecting
everything just from the beginning of
time is this weird butterfly effect
that's causing just time and reality to
shift to be a little bit different and
so now all of the Marty's and all the
Doc Brown's have
work together in one giant Omega yes
it's very it's very freaking Morty uh
but the fact that you just create an
opportunity for Eric Stoltz to come back
and play Marty McFly Larry oh man
and and so time is collapsing on itself
because there's too many branches yes
and so they're gonna collide back
together and create one earth which is
exactly which one is the prime that the
others are like we're okay with not
existing and yeah yeah we're rebooting
the franchise so we can have a new cast
and be able to get another good three
masterpiece god I can't believe you also
you offended me so much you created a
reboot not only another sequel then you
rebooted them joven you got two rogue
E's for just ruining big so much that's
what I wanted Carla Quinn pin that was
one oh yeah I'll be reaching here this
week's theme is pins cute
great great all right all right Eric
show them how it's done ruin my life
why hope it does it because once this
theory came I realize I'm so glad this
came up because I don't know if you
remember Philip for like the past nine
years I have actually been trying to out
lie to develop a Back to the Future
sequel it's not really sequel it's kind
of sequel it's like a tribute film to
Back to the Future that I all I know is
I started with just the title and I'm
like I'm gonna figure out the movie
afterwards it's called back to back to
the future through the future yeah okay
so I if it's okay with you guys I just
like to share with you the pitch for it
because I kind of want to like just get
this on the record just to force myself
to write this like 20 years from now
great yes okay so here's a story back to
back to the future is about a young
movie lover named Eddie who wants to fix
his parents broken marriage he works at
a failing drive-in movie theater for
this kooky film nerd projectionist Jorge
who actually knew Eddie's parents when
they were all teenagers together in the
80s and Jorge recalls to Eddie his
parents first disastrous date which was
like the opening night screening of Back
to the Future in the summer of 85 and
Eddie once he hears the story wishes
that he could go back in time to that
night and make their date a romantic
meet cute and like fix their marriage
restore the marriage give them a nice
meet cute story that they can come back
to anytime they're fighting well it just
so happens this drive-in movie theater
has this old projector screen that they
never use because it's glitchy anytime
they they project a film reel on it
glitches the film there's something
wrong with it
Jorge maybe explains that the screen was
built on like a Fault in space-time and
maybe perhaps in the 80s a young
filmmaker Robert Zemeckis wrote Back to
the Future after seeing a movie at the
Southern California drive-in we can
shine some meta stuff there so he
explains the rules of this world
if Eddie some meta stuff yep if Eddie
were to drive a car 88 miles per hour
directly into that screen the moment the
film reel lights up he will blast
through the screen back in time to the
date that that film reel first projected
on that screen in this case it is the
old print of Back to the Future bringing
it back to 1985 the night of his parents
first date
so once the and then the other rule is
once the film's runtime expires you say
it's two hours or so you return to the
present so you have the duration of the
film itself to do whatever you need to
do so it kind of plays out like Back to
the Future and he tries to play
matchmaker with his parents it gets the
help of nerdy teenage or hey but he
fails because Eddie realizes that his
parents are terrible for each other they
don't belong together
his dad is it the George McFly the story
is that's the bit of the story really he
realizes his mom is better off with
Jorge the nerd
so he lets Jorge and then I I kind of
like going even deeper with it like
maybe he lets Jorge have one date with
his mom in the past maybe they trap time
travel again into the screen going back
to the 50s just letting these two have
their moment together and then it's up
Jorge thanks sim we return to the
present but the president has unchanged
we find out this is why it never worked
out with Eddie's parents it's a fixed
loop we aren't having any time travel
logic problems this is the way it always
was it was always meant to be this way
and Eddie learns that the past is okay
to revisit but we don't need to change
it things are the way they are and that
is okay
just like urbanist al Joe for the Back
to the Future film it's best left in the
past
[Music]
yes was stupid I definitely did not
follow the prompt of the craziest sword
this is like the best version of a Back
to the Future tribute film like if they
go no Eric I really like it I like that
he didn't end up suddenly having Jorge
as a dad and now he's mixed race since
dad comes back and it gets really
complicated for that actor to play that
I also there was a moment where you were
like it turns out he you know he doesn't
think that they should be together and I
was like holy crap Eric can I do the
thing where the kid does get with his
mom there's this arc in my story part of
it yeah yeah it's just your life Eric
great job I'm gonna have to reach in to
a drawer that I did not expect I was
gonna have to reach into anytime soon to
get the bone the silver silver block of
wood this is your payment is silver
worth to normal Rogi yet it's just what
it's worth - well that pays it turns
into an orange in the blue one go Gators
because this was a title I came up with
a weird students at Florida huh there
you go I'm gonna
have the audience tweet at Eric he needs
something other than Sparkle bucks if
he's gonna be playing this go care he
gets no roadies anymore great all right
let's hear them again in the form of a
tweet to Doc Brown's Plus final
destination plus a Lian's equals Back to
the Future four [ __ ] how obvious was
it when you said aliens you were the
meme yeah great joven rumor has it Back
to the Future has a brand-new future
thanks to endgame watch new rock stars
theory on this up next that's a real
tweet he's the only one who does I'm
glad of your from your theory you
brought back the phrase rumor has it
that essential part and Erik I'm sure
you planned your tweet as well as part
of this pitch
I have literally written nothing on
paper for this story including any kind
of marketing material so back to the
future used to be the future now it's
the past we're going to because we're
gonna be at a time summer 2048 2048 have
you gave yourself how much time to write
blame the log of being episode a rogue
theory guys I know all the scores are
really close so let's break it up with
rogue questions all right this week
marks the one year anniversary of the
Game of Thrones finale pour one out now
how are you guys celebrating or honoring
this date I'm celebrating or honoring
this date by I have a garden in my back
yard and I've spent months carefully
cultivating strawberries peppers peppers
I have flowers and pods
I've spinach a lot of stuff and it's
taken me months and to celebrate and
honor this I will burn it all to the
ground appropriate yeah yeah especially
you already have what you want you can
burn it all to the ground great
all right thanks I'm really confused
actually there's a lot of hate for the
final season of Game of Thrones so I
don't know why it got all that hate for
so in honor of this historic date I'm
gonna be watch the whole series all four
seasons I don't know why but like the
doors are gonna shut after they get
brought upstairs the doors shut and then
the credits roll to live in that to live
in that world
for me I will be celebrating by
remembering how full-out
Phillip went with his chunks no cosplay
at our Game of Thrones finale watch
party in New York just to have to
console all the heartbroken pants they
were so mad the show ended the way it
did that night we were so excited for it
and then like everyone's just like what
are we doing and I'm like I got makeup
done to beat look like I'm dead and came
back great all right I'm gonna give that
Rogi to brand for no reason all right
number two this week is the 25th
anniversary of die hard 3 and it's
famous jug riddle scene which doesn't
matter if you don't know it John McClane
is given a three gallon jug and a five
gallon jug and he has to use these to
produce exactly four gallons of water or
kids blow up I think is what it is just
real quick how do you solve that drug
riddle and you drink all the water pee
you urinate into both jugs two gallons
of pee precisely your your bladder sizes
to go yeah I nearly know the answer
it's only because it was also a puzzle
in tomb raider the last revelation they
just completely ripped it off you take
the five gallon drug you poured it in
three gallant rogue filling all the way
leaving two gallons left and then you
empty the three gallon jug and then you
pour in those two gallons from the five
into the three and that leaves one
gallon empty space and then you fill the
five gallon up again any pour exactly
one gallon of that to fill that empty
space and it leaves four yay actually
got lost because you let the kids die
some folks on Twitter this week realized
that one of the closed caption options
on Disney Plus looks a lot like the
silly font Comic Sans so give me your
best Comic Sans voice of a famous movie
line that would be on Disney Plus so a
Disney Plus movie line but what it would
sound like in Comic Sans famous but I'm
trash I'm gonna quote mall in the
wonderful final season of star wars the
clone wars where after his battle with
ahsoka tano he says if you put in comic
sans caption we're all gonna burn droopy
dog all right I'll give you guys marina
to Eric one joven - all right and then
let's hear what our totals are I have
six I have five jumbo
oh great five marinas are winner yes
marina what is your wish that we can
enact immediately oh my wish that you
are gonna enact immediately is that we I
get to wear a crown they're gonna edit a
crown onto me and you guys all have to
wear bunny ears okay
the editors love it when you give the
Hat
alright guys that's it for this episode
of rogue theory thanks do I guess yeah
yeah yeah exactly
don't forget to subscribe to the rogue
theory podcast feed and stay tuned to
the YouTube channel for this and our
other shows follow us on Twitter at new
rock stars follow me it still says this
Zac at EA vasa on the outro but also
maybe follow at Phillip Molina but say
thank you so much joven where can we
find you and where what's your new thing
- oh we also got a new brought all my
friends back together no you're playing
a gaming stuff and podcast stuff so you
can go check that out at youtube.com
slash new element 6 thanks for making
the Eric what's going on this week not
doing that voice we're doing mine no we
got reg Rock coming your way
yeah alright don't worry about it they
know to just be subscribe hit the bell
and Madame rabbit queen queen of rabbits
not as we are stung yeah alright guys
thank you so much for going rogue you
guys could've stopped watching minutes
ago nothing really thank you alright
fun episode thank you guys so much have
a good one alright bye bye
[Music]